Wow I'm in the steps are pretty guy
remember it so you don't have to we've
all used the phrase so bad it's good the
room troll to plan 9 from outer space
and yes a whole shit ton of Nicolas Cage
movies am I getting free do oh we laugh
at its awkwardness and just how kooky
and strange it can be but what separates
bad movies that we like from bad movies
that we hate why can we watch Birdemic
or santa claus conquers the Martians
with joy and yet legitimately hate films
like The Adventures of Pluto Nash or
transformers 2 well let's ask ourselves
what are we trying to get out of film to
submit to an illusion because when you
get down to it all we're really doing is
sitting down in a chair looking at a
screen not very exciting but it's the
ability to be engrossed into what's
appearing on the screen that you forget
that's actually what you're doing people
claim that watching gravity was very
similar to feeling like you were up in
space that's an example of an illusion
working so good that you believe you're
actually there and that's exactly what a
movie is supposed to do make you forget
that you're sitting there doing nothing
but trick you into getting sucked into a
story or a character's dial Emma that
you want to know the outcome to that's
all the more important to understand
this when the illusion is done wrong
when the characters are not believable
the situation's not engrossing and the
experience just all-around not
entertaining if you get a bad actor a
bad writer the illusion is ruined much
easier because you're constantly
reminded that what you're watching is
not real and even though we know that
going in we still want to partake in the
willingness to believe that the illusion
is really happening in front of us but
if the people making the movie aren't
talented enough or not trying hard
enough we're often stuck being reminded
that we are just looking at a screen for
an hour and a half and what's happening
on the screen is not very engaging
so we know that's what bad are can do
but what's the transition of going from
bad artists so bad it's good art a
comedy for example usually has the main
purpose of making you laugh so what the
jokes characters or situations aren't
funny you've almost no way of getting
your audience back however when a drama
is trying to be serious and fails at a
spectacular degree you find yourself
entertained why because you know what
the movie is trying to do and now you
laugh at how hard it's not doing it you
start to question how could anyone think
this monster was real how could anyone
believe that what this person is saying
was supposed to be natural why would
anybody wear tuxes to play football the
lack of commitment to the illusion has
now become kind of fascinating you laugh
at how much you question the filmmakers
choices the pattern seems to be the more
things wrong with the movie the more
entertainingly horrible it is the acting
alone in Birdemic is funny but add on
top of it horrible effects horrible
writing horrible editing and horrible
cinematography and you have a
blue-ribbon disasterpiece
guaranteed to make people laugh in the
aisles but there's other movies that
have similar elements and yet don't get
quite the same reaction for example the
postman is a pretty bad movie is now
well written now well acted and not well
directed but this film isn't
entertainingly bad it's just bad but why
what is this film doing different that
Birdemic isn't well this film doesn't
entertain because it's boring the
choices the director makes are awful but
not laughable the acting is bad but not
the worst and the Lighting's lame but
not funny late so what then makes the
distinction between a bad film and a
hilariously bad film well part of it in
this case is that Costner to be fair is
a competent director he knows how to
frame a straightforward shot he knows
how to tell a basic story he knows not
to pick really bad actors if they
audition Costner even though he didn't
do it well in this case has some idea
what he's doing
which is why it's so much more fun when
you come across someone who doesn't know
what they're doing a person who will try
anything even if
doesn't make a lick of sense it's the
incompetence that makes the illusion all
the more broken and thus all the more
laughable on top of that there's
something to be said about a project
where simply nobody cares Star Trek the
motion picture for example is said to be
the worst Star Trek film because nobody
wanted to work on it even the director
these are all talented people who were
told to give more of a 2001 a Space
Odyssey film more than a Star Trek film
because of that nobody got into the
movie they were making and it's said to
be the most boring Star Trek film out of
all of them by contrast a film by Ed
Wood is far worse put together but you
know that he was excited and dedicated
in every single shot it's just that his
direction was always blindsided by his
own naivete or lack of patience but that
passion can still go a long way when
someone has that much drive constantly
pointed in the wrong direction the
outcome has to be interesting to say the
least it's like if someone misheard
instead of making a chimney out of
bricks they should make it out of chips
well it fails as a chimney but good
fucking god look at that thing that
isn't like anything any of us have ever
seen before
and that's what makes something so bad
it's good it shows us something that we
haven't seen before we've seen Kevin
Costner act boring in a film but we
haven't seen Tommy was so humping a
dress we've seen Mark Wahlberg at
generically tough but we haven't seen
him act as the world's biggest confused
whim fighting off trees what know so
it's not how bad the movie is it's how
intriguingly bad it is and how often
it's that intriguingly bad and how
passionately often it's that
intriguingly bad some may look at these
bad films and simply save their bad
films nothing more but for others we see
the questions that may never get
answered and quite frankly we probably
don't want them ever to be answered it
would ruin what makes them so strangely
entertaining whether it's a bizarrely
bad script a bizarrely bad director a
bizarrely bad editor or yes even a
bizarrely
over-the-top performance there is so
much goodness to be found in badness
hijk LMNOP tu me to my face fuck that's
all you have to do I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to